[Music]
hello there and welcome to
your introduction to cobol no matter
what brought you here we're glad to see
you
and hope that you enjoy all that went
into creating these videos
first things first what is cobalt well
whenever there's an acronym
i like to start there and cobalt is an
acronym for
common business oriented language that's
a big tell right there right in the name
this is a business language compared
with other more general purpose
languages cobol was designed around
data processing specifically data
processing with incredibly high accuracy
extreme efficiency and ease of reading
and writing
cobol has indeed been around for over 60
years as of this recording
and surprise surprise the fundamentals
of business
being able to process very large amounts
of data accurately and efficiently
continue to be important so all of the
transactions that happen when you're
using a credit card
visiting a store or doing pretty much
anything with a bank
there's a good chance some cobalt code
got executed
somewhere in there in fact every day
about three trillion dollars in finance
gets handled by cobalt so let's just
make sure we're clear here
cobalt pretty much runs the world it has
been kept
up to date to support new requirements
throughout the years and
1.5 billion lines of new code are
written
every year suffice to say learning this
language will give you a
very valuable set of skills in this
course you're going to be working with
enterprise cobol which is an
implementation written specifically to
run
on ibm z mainframes the banks insurance
agencies
energy companies retail chains that
depend on cobalt to run their extremely
important transactions
guess what a whole lot of them also
depend on ibm z mainframes
to ensure their applications can keep up
with the demand
24x7 learning enterprise cobol
says i want to work on the most
important code
running on the most important systems
running the types of things that
no exaggeration at all the world depends
on
that's a pretty bold statement and i
have no problem at all saying it because
it's the truth
[Music]
you might be thinking cobalt on the
mainframe
am i going to need punch cards and a tie
to get through this
well first of all no you'll be happy to
know that we're going to be teaching all
this with
visual studio code which as of right now
is the most popular editor
used worldwide visual studio code or
vs code for short supports something
called language server protocol which
simply put makes it able to support a
very large
number of languages and environments so
the things you'd expect to be there like
code completion
workspace symbols hover text references
and diagnostics
can all be supported without it having
to be specifically written into vs code
itself
it gains functionality through
extensions which
use the language server protocol or lsp
we're going to use extensions for vs
code that give us all the goodness for
cobalt
as well as allowing us to connect to a
real live mainframe system
so after you download and install vs
code
hop into the extensions marketplace and
search for ibm z
open editor and hit the install button
while
that's installing do the same for zoe
explorer z-o-w-e
that's the simple version of things for
more detailed instructions on installing
the extensions
visit the book version for the full
details and screenshots
couple of basics once you're in you'll
also notice these vertical lines
very important for cobalt these are the
margins
those margins segment each line of
cobalt code into its various parts
which we'll get into later on just know
that it's
easier to see whether your text is
starting right next to a line
than it is to count empty spaces so
lines
good also if you hover your mouse over
some fields a little pop-up box will
appear
showing you additional information just
know that this will come in really handy
when you really start hacking away at
cobalt code later on
and you may also notice that some words
get displayed differently than others
that's all part of syntax highlighting
it just makes things a little bit easier
to
understand at a glance and this bar
across the top
that's the breadcrumb view it shows
information about what line you're
currently
at click on any element in that
breadcrumb trail
and it will highlight the block of text
for that element it'll also show you a
little outline view of the code
over here lastly down at the bottom of
your screen there should be a panel with
a problem
section and if it's not there go up to
view
and select problems from the editor menu
you can click on the problems it is
found and it will jump
right to those in the code it will find
basic logical errors without you having
to run
or test your code it just knows about
those problems ahead of time
so you'll definitely want to fix those
as they come up
got all that i'd say you're ready to
dive into some actual cobalt
so let's go
cobalt is an english-like computer
language it's that way
by design meaning it's fairly easy to
read
understand and maintain compared with
other programming languages you'll find
that each line of code is pretty
transparent
about what it's trying to do that's
often the first thing people notice
about cobol that what it's trying to do
is very easy to figure out and you don't
have to spend a whole lot of time
tracing through code to make sense of it
all
that's thanks in part to cobalt being
standardized
so the way that a cobalt implementation
should be approached
is all described in great detail in that
standardization
now cobol has gone through several
revisions over the years
so you do need to keep in mind which
particular standard you're working with
particularly
when you're working with code outside of
this course but it mostly comes down to
the addition of a few
new features better support and small
tweaks to fix
problems cobalt written specifically for
the ibm z mainframe operating system
z os is said to be enterprise cobol
the code you'll see here in this course
is all enterprise cobol
and it all gets compiled and executed
differently than cobalt
you might be writing for other platforms
but it is also able to take advantage of
hardware and operating system features
unavailable anywhere else so it still
follows the current cobalt
standardization but it's written
with enterprise systems in mind let's
take a look
at some of the basic cobol syntax at a
high level
so you can get a better feel for the
cobalt standard right up front
one of the key aspects of cobalt some
languages use spaces
some use tabs cobalt is column dependent
meaning it looks at a line of code and
expects certain things to be at certain
positions
in that line specifically it's looking
in
five key areas of a 72 character line
and those look like this the first
section
columns one through six are the sequence
number
area sometimes these are blank other
times we use them to provide
context to a series of statements the
next section is the
indicator area and it's a multi-purpose
area
if we're going to leave a comment an
asterisk a star
goes in here or if we're continuing a
previous line it'll be a dash or
a hyphen it can also be a d for a
debugging line
or a slash for source code listing
formatting
don't worry about all that just yet
we'll show you how and why you'll use
those later on just remember
it's column seven and it's one character
next we've got the a area which goes
from columns
eight to eleven in here you'll find
divisions
sections paragraphs level indicators and
other elements
that give cobalt programs their
structure
right next to it in columns 12 through
72 is the b
area this is where you put the actual
statements
sentences and clauses the things that
make a cobol program
perform calculations and do stuff
then last but not least the
identification area running from column
73 to 80. well the compiler might
consider at least because it actually
ignores it so it doesn't consider it at
all it's
actually an area the programmer can use
for any purpose
so it's often just left blank now when
you're writing in a programming language
there are certain words we have to be
careful of
words like data end file if
ready set until those
are cobalt reserve words and when the
cobalt compiler sees those words
it thinks we're telling it to do
something very specific
so we shouldn't say ready unless we mean
what the compiler thinks
it means a full list of reserve words is
available
at the link in your guide in the next
video
we're going to talk about how all this
fits together in the program
structure
[Music]
let's talk structure koval has a
hierarchy structure
meaning that it's got things within
other things that's part of what gives
it its structure
the biggest things in a cobalt program
are divisions
and within those divisions there are
sections and within those sections
you'll find paragraphs
those paragraphs contain sentences and
sentences have statements let's start at
the statement and work our way back out
a statement is a single directive
usually starting with one of those
reserved words we just talked about
so something like add divide move
compute those statements go into
sentences
just like a spoken sentence can reveal
many pieces of information
a cobalt sentence can contain one or
more statements
it's just a nice way of placing a bunch
of statements together
into a logical container so here is a
sentence
made up of statements and you can see
that the end there is a period
that period is an implicit scope
terminator it says
all the previous statements that have
not yet ended are declared
as finished you can also terminate a
scope of a statement using what's known
as an explicit scope terminator
like if you started with an if statement
and you end with an
end if then you don't need to specify
that you're done with a period
either way works and you'll see both
used throughout this course
so that's sentences and what do
sentences go into
well generally paragraphs paragraphs are
user defined
written by you to give your program
structure
generally a paragraph represents a
specific action
made up of smaller steps so if it's
something that might get called several
times throughout your program
like applying interest or prompting the
user for a series of input
that would go into a paragraph that way
you can call that paragraph
by its name from elsewhere in the
program paragraphs go into
sections and there are all sorts of
sections they can have
user defined or predefined names so they
can be used to give your program
structure
or to make sure certain information is
where it needs to be for things to run
correctly
and then there's divisions and there are
four cobalt divisions
and we can cover all those right now
first is the identification division
which is where you'd put the name of
your program who wrote it
when it was written how it should be
used all that helpful information
then there's the environment division
there are two
major sections here one lets you set the
type of computer environment required to
run your program
and the other sets of the mapping
between the files in your program
and the files on the actual data sets so
it's the link between your program
and the system it's running on the data
division
sets up all the data that will be used
within your program
that includes files data from other
programs what type of storage or
memory you'll use while the program is
running and what it will give up when
the program ends
then there's the procedure division this
is where all those sections and
paragraphs go
so the instructions for how to take data
in how to set up the variables
performing math on them interacting with
the user and all that kind of fun stuff
that happens in the procedure division
are you ready to see all those
statements divisions sentences and
paragraphs and actions
i sure hope so because it's time for a
lab basic
cobol syntax in this lab you'll connect
to an ibm z
system check out a simple cobol hello
world program
and then submit the jcl to compile the
program and view the output
good luck and have fun
[Music]
in this section we're going to talk all
about cobol
variables i'm pretty sure every
programming language
in existence has variables of some sort
and even
basic algebra has the concept of having
a letter
represent a value like x equals 5.
cobalt is really no different though it
does put its own spin on some of the
details
which we'll cover here simply put a
variable is a name
chosen by the programmer to represent a
value
that name is referred to as a data name
that data name can be anything
as long as it's 30 characters or less
doesn't contain any spaces is made up of
only letters digits and or hashes
and isn't a reserved word so
some examples of good data names might
be balance
inventory one two three four five and
north american sales in 2020-final
that's exactly 30 characters there will
be no problem with any of those however
if we wanted a
data name of top five percent with a
percent sign
or phone numbers with a space in the
middle
those would not be good we also have to
think about
what type of variable we want because
when we declare or
create a variable we have to tell cobalt
what it's going to be
numeric just numbers alphabetic just
letters
or both alphanumeric we also have to
tell
just how many of those letters and or
numbers we think we're going to be using
and we do all this because cobalt is an
extremely
efficient programming language and part
of what lets it be so efficient
is knowing exactly what's going on with
all of its data
right from the beginning we set this up
in the
picture clause picture or pick for short
sets the length and the data type of a
programmer selected variable name
so pic9 is a single numeric value where
the length is
1. the 9 means numeric it doesn't mean
it's a value of 9 or a length of 9
it just means here's a variable of
numeric type and since we didn't specify
a length we only get one it defaults to
one
so i don't know maybe we're programming
an elevator in a building with nine
floors we could use that to store
what floor we're currently on could be
handy for that
and if we need more than one digit we
can specify that within the parentheses
like here
pick 9 parentheses 4. that says it's a
numeric variable
and there's four of them that might be a
good place to store
perhaps the year because obviously you
would need
four digits to represent a year like
2020
or 2021 or 55 45 or 1999
four digits for the year always
pick a means we have a single alphabetic
character
and because we didn't specify length we
only get one so i could use that to
store my favorite letter
z pick x
eight gives us eight alphanumeric
characters
x means alphanumeric and with that many
i could store
a us license plate made up of up to
eight letters and numbers
now not all pick clauses are created
equal
so you need to know that the maximum
length of a numeric picture clause is 18
while an alphabetic pick clause can be
up to 255
and know that there are lots of other
types of pick clauses
we will dive into those as we need them
for now just focus on those
three numeric alphabetic and
alphanumeric
you can use picture clauses to represent
symbols that appear
in the value so for example pick nine
parentheses four v nine what the heck
does that mean
well nine parentheses four means there's
four digits
then we've got a v which represents the
decimal position the dot
then two more nines so two more digits
we can use this pick clause to represent
1425.82
that could be a radio frequency or a
measurement of some sort
we can also do something like this pick
dollar sign
9 comma nine nine nine v
nine nine that can be used to represent
one thousand two hundred and thirty four
dollars and fifty six cents the
dollar sign and comma carry through and
the v
indicates the decimal area when we think
of a variable
we often think about something variable
meaning it can change
cobalt also has things called literals
which contain data that will not change
during the course of the program
so i might use a literal to store
something that i'm going to use several
times in a program
but only want to have to set it once for
all those other places
so maybe the name of a company a string
of characters that i use to separate
lines and output
or copyright information anything that's
going to get used more than once and
isn't going to change
while a program is running cobol has a
few
figurative literals built in to make
things easier
you can use them without setting them up
yourself and a few you'll find most
handy
are zero and zeros space and spaces
low value high value null nulls and
you'll notice that for some of these
there's a singular as well as a plural
version very handy
so if you're starting a new variable and
you want it to be all spaces
the efficient way to set that up is
using the spaces
literal rather than sitting there and
going space basically
using literals is what efficient
programmers do
and i want you to be an efficient
programmer
up next our good friend the data
[Music]
division
all of the data you're going to use in
your program gets set up in the data
division
to add structure to this we use what's
called a data relationship
we can see that by looking at this
segment of code right here in this data
division
we've got level indicators each with
their own descriptive entry
print rec has a level indicator of 01
meaning it's the highest
and then the data definitions are below
it at 0
5. and the file account rec has its own
set of variables
with their own level indicators down
here don't you just love that structure
it's basically saying the data this file
needs are the account fields
and then below it it spells out exactly
what those account fields are
so we've declared the data let's do
something with it
move and compute are reserved words that
we use to alter the value of variables
move does well you probably figured it
out it
moves the data from one place into a
variable and
compute is used to perform math so in
this example we've got a bunch of 77
level variables up top
which are who where why rate hours and
gross pay
you'll notice the first three are
alphanumeric and the last three
are numeric then down in the procedure
division
we're using move to set up some of those
variables the
who where and why are captain cobalt san
jose california
and learn to be a cobol expert and
that's spelled out pretty clearly on
those lines
we're also setting the hours and rate to
19
and 23. we are not going to set the
gross pay
with a move instead we're going to use
compute
and set that to the answer of our times
rate and then lastly we'll output the
values of our variables
with some text before them so the person
using the program
knows what value they're looking at
pretty simple right
good because it's um oh yeah
it's time for a lab take a look at the
payroll zero zero cobalt source code in
the id.cbl dataset
and when you're ready to give it a try
make sure you're submitting the jcl
for it and not the cobol itself you
submit the jcl
to run the cobol got that i know you do
have fun
[Music]
up until now we've mostly been moving
data between variables taking them from
user input or outputting them to a
display
now we're going to take things to the
next level and start working with
files to do this we're going to use
select and assign clauses in the
environment division
fd statements in the data division and
from the procedure division
open close read into and write from
statements the environment and data
division
is where we describe our inputs and
outputs which will get used in the
procedure division
because as we all know that's where the
action happens
let's take a look at that action in
action here you can see the
file control paragraph in the input
output section
of the environment division what we're
doing here is associating each cobalt
internal file name with an
external data set name in this case
print
line is the name of the internal file
name and
p-r-t-l-i-n-e is the external data set
or file so that's the select and assign
clauses
in the environment division further down
in the data division this is where we
define the level numbers
variable names data types and lengths
the fd reserve word is used to give the
cobalt compiler more information about
those internal file names
so print line which is linked with the
data set
file prt lina has these
fields types and lengths and account rec
which is linked to a cct rec
has these fields types and lengths
when your cobalt code is running on an
ibm z mainframe it'll have access to
both traditional z os data sets as well
as
unix files for right now we're going to
focus on the z os sequential data
storage method
because it's extremely common and a good
place to start when working with files
in cobol
a data set in z os is made up of records
and you can think of each record as a
line within a data set
with a defined length so like anything
written out row by row
you'll find the exact value you're
looking for by scanning down to the
right record
and then across for the field you want
if you take
all these fields and add up their length
that makes up the entirety of the length
of that record
you got it it's kind of simple the way
data input
output or io is handled is a program
says hey
i'd like to read this piece of data out
here
and then the operating system or data io
subsystem goes and gets it and places it
into memory
where the program can go and read it if
a program is requesting lots and lots of
reads one right after the other
that's a lot of i o operations which is
somewhat inefficient and can lead to
slow performance
it would be like going into a restaurant
and ordering a soda and then waiting
until that's brought out and saying you
know what i'd also like a hamburger
then they bring that out you say fries
too and they bring that out and you say
ketchup and then they throw you out of
the restaurant because that's extremely
inefficient and annoying
and we don't want to be inefficient or
annoying in cobalt programming we have
this concept of something called
blocks because we know so much about the
records
we can load data as a block where a
block
is a group of records as long as the
program is going to read
one record followed by the next followed
by the next and so on
we can get the records we want in order
into what's called a
buffer take a look at this we can see a
block of records loaded into a buffer
where the overall
record length is the size of each field
combined
we set that overall block size in the
buffer with the
block contains clause earlier we used
the assign clause to describe a data set
source file
we said select account rack with a dash
in it
assigned to account rec if we're running
this in z os
using jcl we need to have a jcl dd
statement to link account rec
to that actual data set the jcl required
for the cobalt compiler to make the
connection back to the actual data set
looks something like this slash slash
account rec
d d d s n equals my.data
comma disp equals shr
if you're unfamiliar with jcl this is a
data declaration statement that's what
the dd stands for
it says that for account rec look here
at my.data
the disk equals shr just means it
expects
that the data set exists before we try
to use it and that other people can use
it at the same time we don't require
exclusive access
now i don't know about you but i kind of
want to see this all spelled out from
end to end so
we'll start out with account rec that's
what we reference within our procedure
division in the actual
code account rec is what's defined in
the environment division's
input output section slash slash
account rec a cct rec seven characters
then gets connected via a dd statement
to my.data the actual data set on the
disk
now don't sweat the jcl stuff too much
right now i know you came here to learn
cobol
not jcl and chances are if you're given
some code to write or modify
somebody will prepare that jcl for you
or at least tell you what data sets and
names to use so you won't have to guess
there's a link to an online resource for
basic jcl concepts in the course notes
if you're curious though
one other important note the cobalt
compiler assumes
that what you tell it for the file names
is true
and correct and it will work when it
goes to run because it doesn't have any
way of checking what's actually in your
jcl or actually on the file system
and if any part of that chain is broken
or not correctly linked
you're going to get an error at run time
that's why it's important to have a good
naming scheme because
chasing those types of errors is no fun
at all
up next we'll talk about putting all
that to use in the procedure division
[Music]
now we're in the procedure division
where we actually open those files
that happens in the open file section
and we can open
files for input and output like this
here we've got account rec
open for input and print line open for
output and just as we open the file we
should really make sure to close them
when we're done this can be done at the
program completion
or if it's going to be a long running
program when we're done using that file
resource
we do that with the close dash stop
so we just say close account dash rec
and then close print dash line and then
stop run
stops the processing because cobalt
is often used to handle lots and lots of
data it's a
safe assumption that we'll need a way to
process records
one after the other until we're done you
may have seen in other programming
languages the concept of a
for or a do statement cobalt uses
perform
and in practice it looks like this i
encourage you to hit the pause
button on this screen and study it for a
little bit because while it's extremely
straightforward there are a few bits in
here that might raise an eyebrow
and we'll go through all of that so i'm
stalling here to give you time to find
the pause button
and we're back so starting at the top
we've got the read next record paragraph
the first thing we're going to do here
is perform a read record that's the
first line
there are no conditions about it we're
going to do a read
record at least once that read dash
record is defined down here
that is going to read the next record
from the file
and if we're at the end put a y
presumably for yes
into lastrack then when we're done
reading
we have this end read and even though
that terminates logically
and explicitly with the end read it also
terminates
implicitly with that period there so
we're just being complete covering all
of our bases
now going back up into the read next
record
we're indenting and our first line here
is a perform until
it says perform until last rec equals y
and why would last rec equals y it would
be y
if read record detected it hit the
bottom and it processed its last record
and if that file was empty it would hit
this first perform put a y
into last rec and then the logic of this
until statement
would say we're done performing we're
bumped out of the logic
because there's nothing left to do here
and we've also hit this implicit
terminator
so we're done with this paragraph if the
file is
empty if the file has a couple of
records in it like we would expect
then we continue and we're going to do a
write record with the data we just got
that's defined down at the bottom of the
example code
then we'll do another read record before
going back up to the top of this perform
loop
where we'll check to see if we got a y
if it does
we'll end if it's values then we're
going to use write record to write them
out
continuing that process until we've hit
the bottom of the file
setting last rec to y and finishing
reading a file from top to bottom is
like the c major scale of cobalt
programming you're going to have to do a
lot of it
so you should know how to do it forwards
and backwards and this code right here
is a
great example of this type of logic done
right
keep all that good stuff in mind as we
go into lab number
three you'll use everything we touched
on in this lesson to fix some code
remember that the all important chain of
links between the procedure variables
environment variables and the jcl data
sets
needs to be correct and if it helps
write them out so you can double check
things as you write it
go get to it lab number three
[Music]
you'll often hear cobalt referred to as
a structured programming language in
this definition
structured means that it relies on the
concept of passing control
and adhering to a flow structure as a
program executes
in other words the way that you write
your code is used to spell out
how it should be executed people writing
code in c
pli python and of course cobalt use the
structure of their languages to ensure
code flows
exactly the way it ought to another
style of programming known as object
oriented programming
divides code up into smaller segments
called classes
each having its own specific purpose and
each class has its own set of variables
and
methods then once the classes are
defined you write the code that
describes the interaction
between them all and if you're writing a
program where you're going to benefit
from this type of class
object relationship it allows for you to
write very
capable code without needing to define
each and every instance
of each and every class from scratch
every single time
however i can tell you from a little bit
of experience that it's also very easy
to write something that looks very
simple
but behaves completely different from
what you intended
you're essentially building the
structure of code on the fly and that
has its advantages
but a lot of the code people write on
cobalt needs to be
transparent and readable and easily
diagnosed
which is a lot easier to do in a
structured language
you get the ability to jump around a
little bit in cobalt but you should be
sure to use those sparingly and not rely
on them to provide the backbone of your
program
as we saw before cobalt passes control
primarily using the perform keyword
and using paragraphs so how can we best
make use of this structure
i'm so glad you asked let's take a look
at basic program control and flow
through a snippet of code we're setting
up the output of
print line we're setting the message
headers of print rec
to the number is and then we're adding
one to the counter variable
moving that value to message to right
and then writing print rec
which will print something like the
number is one
then we do the same thing again with the
exact same code
adding one moving it to message to right
and printing it for as many times as we
feel like repeating in this section here
the only indication i have that i might
be done
is that the name of the program is 2 10
1 so i can assume we'll do this 10 times
a simple looking program but dreadfully
repetitive and not a very good use of
anybody's time remember we want to be
efficient and that doesn't look
efficient
those three lines of code keep getting
written again and again
and again so rather than typing them out
let's address that issue right here
we'll move those three lines of code
into a new paragraph
called write new record and then we'll
just call that paragraph 10 times using
the perform keyword
so the program will get here then run
this
then go here then run this and i'll do
that 10 times
this is called an out of line perform
statement because it requires jumping
down here
and then back up and it's definitely
less code but it still seems kind of
repetitive right
that's where we need to look into using
a loop using an inline perform statement
and once i pop that up on the screen
you'll see exactly what i mean
in the previous versions the part of the
code we were repeating
was add one to the counter move that
counter value to
message to right and then writing it out
here we see the move counter statement
that looks the same
and here's that print wreck we wrap
those two lines
in this perform and end perform which
forms our loop
so what about incrementing the content
of counter
that happens as a condition of the loop
itself
perform that sets up the loop varying
counter from
0 1 by 1 until counter equals 11.
that i mean we really don't have to
spell out what it does right it
basically looks like english
perform a loop where each iteration of
the loop increases the counter by one
starting from one until we get to 11.
why did we say 11 we had to say 11
because if we said
10 we would hit 10 after incrementing it
match this until clause and bump out
before executing the move and print part
you'll see a logic like this in other
languages like this java example
obviously the cobalt version involves a
lot more typing but it's easier to read
and you'll also get autocomplete so your
editor will write a lot of that for you
another way you can get around this is
by using a go to
now here's the thing about go to
don't use go to unless you absolutely
have to do it and you
absolutely know exactly what it's going
to do
go to does exactly what it sounds like
it jumps the program to where you're
directing it
and it just kind of picks up and runs
from there the difference between go to
and perform
is that instead of it being a special
assignment that will do
and then return from it's just gonna go
there and start executing from there
it's like when you're reading something
online you see a word or a phrase you
don't understand so you search for it
and you find a video about it and you
watch that video ideally you go
okay cool now i understand that and you
jump back to where you were
or if you're like me you go hey that was
kind of cool
what was i looking at again and there
goes the whole afternoon
if you were to go back to that program
we showed earlier and replaced the
second
perform write new record call with a go
to
right new record like this the program
would jump ahead to the right new record
paragraph
execute it and then just keep on going
because it didn't know that was on a
special assignment
it just thought okay well this is where
i am now just understand the difference
and be careful when using go-to
statements because
you might be losing some of that
structure that your program needs to be
successful
if that didn't make sense you might want
to re-watch this video and check your
notes because
right now we're going to go to the next
video
[Music]
when you start planning a program start
thinking in paragraphs
if you were to start whiteboarding the
overall flow of a program
drawing words and boxes and connecting
those boxes with arrows
a lot of those boxes will get
implemented as paragraphs and that's
good that's kind of the point
a paragraph gets defined in the
procedure division
starts at column eight and can have any
name you like
apart from a reserved cobol keyword the
declaration of a paragraph is terminated
with a period
the paragraph itself can contain one to
many
cobalt sentences and is terminated by
either the start of another paragraph
or the end of the entire program from an
application architecture perspective you
really want to spend some time
up front charting out the flow of your
program and deciding what part will get
handled
in what paragraph if you start this way
instead of kind of figuring it out as
you go along
not only will your code be less error
prone you'll have a nice reference to
use later on
now there are two big situations where a
light should go on over your head and
you'll say to yourself ah
that's a good use for a paragraph the
first is if you find yourself typing the
same couple of lines over and over and
over again like
adding a bunch of numbers together and
finding the average
if you find yourself doing that think
about packaging those
up into a paragraph and giving it a name
and by the way
put at least a few seconds of thought
into your paragraph names
nobody wants to open up a bunch of
source code to find paragraphs called
do file stuff or test123
aim for something like open input files
or
check for duplicates that way you know
exactly what's going on in there
also if you've got a couple of lines
that need to happen a bunch of times
extracting those lines into a paragraph
and using a perform
keyword to execute them a certain number
of times
or until a certain condition is met is
good practice for writing comprehensive
code
a paragraph can come before or after the
code calling it
but you should try to order your
paragraphs close to the order that
they'll be executed in at run time
just to make it easier to find them what
i'm saying is don't just throw new
paragraphs at the bottom of the program
you may see people start their
paragraphs with numbers and each
paragraph will look like
one thousand dash open files two
thousand dash
read next record and so on then as you
extend your program you can add them
into the appropriate significant digit
that way you can say you know what that
paragraph should be in the three
thousands and so on
we kind of don't have to rely on this
anymore with modern editors that can
quickly jump between the paragraphs of a
program
but this explains why you might see this
done in code that you're looking at
and you may or may not choose to do the
same when you write yours
you may also see empty paragraphs at the
end of other paragraphs
like this the open files end paragraph
has
no code and does nothing but for someone
reading through code it makes a nice
visual
indicator that the code for this
paragraph ends here
it also comes into play if you're using
the perform through keyword
which we'll learn about in just a little
bit one of the simplest ways of setting
up a loop
is with times for example here we say
perform
10 times and then some code finishing
with
end perform and we can set that up with
a number
just like that or with a numeric
variable like this
perform my new paragraph counter times
whatever counter is it'll perform that
paragraph that many times
we can also perform through and this can
be spelled out through
or just th r u check out this example
we have our first paragraph 1000
paragraph a
that says perform 2000 paragraph b
through 3000 paragraph c this is another
reason to consider the order that you
state your paragraphs
now we'll hit this perform through jump
down and execute paragraph
b and c and then finish this paragraph
we'll never hit
d because we were only performing
through paragraph c
we can also perform until which will
evaluate the check
and if that condition is not met it'll
take some action
this is usually done until a number hits
a certain level
or two variables are the same like
increment
this value until it's equal to that
value
in this example the order is that we do
the check and then do the code and if
the condition
is met we're done we've done it until
if that doesn't match your logic we can
also do perform until
with test after like here this will run
the loop
and then do the test there's also
perform
varying where we say something like
perform
varying counter from 0 1 by 1
until counter equals 11. we just looked
at that earlier
and if you really want to get fancy you
can nest those performs like this where
we've got two counters going on
counter and counter two and every time
we increment counter
by one we're going to step counter two
from
one to five in increments of one so we
would get one
one two three four five two one two
three four five
three one two three four five and so on
now
i don't know about you but i'm starting
to get a little loopy myself
in the next video we'll cover linking in
other cobol programs
a cobalt program can call other cobalt
programs
and you do that with the call keyword
followed by the name of the program
that can be call prog a1 with the
literal program name being in single
quotes
or like this where we move the program
name to a variable and then call that
variable
the way a calling program calls a called
program is through something called
linkage and i'm going to show you a very
basic example
of it the program being called has this
section
called the linkage section and in here
it defines
three variables month day and year
they're all numeric two digits for month
and day and four for year of
course there's four for year and they've
all got an ls
at the end so you know they're in the
linkage section as opposed to the
variables up here in the working storage
section which have a ws at the end
so this program over here that we're
calling it knows that it's going to be
called
and it prepares itself by setting up the
linkage section
it also sets up the procedure division
using the
using keyword so it's going to use those
three variables from the linkage section
in addition to the three variables from
the data division
working storage section now the calling
program
sets up those three variables in
preparation for this
which in this case matched the variables
in the linkage
section we want to set those up just
like any other variable
then we do this call date sub
using month out day out year out there's
those three variables
we're calling that other program and
giving it those three variables to store
the output that it generates
linking programs can get quite
complicated but
for now we're just going to leave it at
that just know that there are
ways of passing actual data as opposed
to references to data
mechanisms for getting a return value
from a called program and
all other sorts of goodies once a
program reaches a certain size you're
almost guaranteed to see everything
we've talked about
in these last few videos put to use so
if this all makes sense
you're in good shape let's keep this
party going
[Music]
a big part of cobalt is generating
reports you've got
tons and tons and tons of data and you
need a way
to produce a report of that data so
someone else can look at it and go
hmm yes
yes that's very good yes
for that reason we've spelled out an
example of generating report data here
which can be very easily scaled out to
handle multiple records
and called any number of different ways
at the end you'll be asked to complete a
lab that puts all of this to use
previously we looked at the select and
respective assign
programmer chosen names we had something
like this in the environment division we
used print
line as the internal cobalt file name
for the output
now in the file descriptor marked by fd
within the file control paragraph we
start to connect it all together
the fd entry defines the layout of the
record
within that print line internal file
and you can see you were saying fd is a
file the highest level descriptor is
print
wreck and then within that print wreck
we have the individual
fields defined first account number
o presumably for output that's a value
of eight alphanumeric characters
then look at this filler that's an odd
name for a field and it's actually not a
field but a cobalt reserved word
remember those we use filler to allocate
memory space
typically between words or variables and
filler can be
empty it can be dashes or any literal
in this example it's eight characters of
account number
then two spaces and you can see that we
spelled out spaces there with
s-p-a-c-e-s that's a handy shortcut so
you don't actually have to type out the
spaces
each one of those filler lines in here
is just inserting two empty spaces and
in this case it might seem somewhat
basic but without filler your reports
would just be a bunch of values slammed
up against one another
consider this partial program this is
the working storage section we've got
four headers defined there's no logic in
here this is just something that defines
what our data looks like
notice we've got some areas up here that
are just filler and we're filling them
up with this
text financial report for
then in header two it's a mixture of
literal labels and
printed out variables so we'll have the
word year
notice it's year with a space at the end
of it and that's why it's five
characters then the value of hdr
year header year same with month and day
header three is all filler it's just
account
two spaces last name two spaces limit
two spaces and
balance and then forty spaces if you
need
forty spaces for your account balance i
wanna be your friend
send me an email once you're done
learning cobalt
then in header four this is more filler
it's eight
dashes two spaces ten dashes two spaces
and so on so what i see up here so far
is a header that goes up top and that
says what the report is
and then there's some sort of header
info that spells out the time period the
report is for
which is kind of important and then
we've got two headers for the values
which i'm assuming will be listed out
below makes sense so far
so that header too that's date info the
data name layout for the date info is
defined here and it's
kind of neat how this works the high
level variable
name is ws current date
data that's ws for working storage
and then within that we've got two
sections ws
current date and ws current time
the date is divided up into the year
month and day and the time is divided up
into hours
minutes seconds and milliseconds now we
know exactly what that
current date data looks like
which is good because that's one of the
first things we're going to do
in the procedure division aka the
division where all the action happens
check out this procedure division we
start out with a paragraph called
write headers and then we've got these
four move sentences the first one takes
the current date
from what's known as an intrinsic
function more on that later
but what it does is it takes the current
date of when that code is actually
executed
and it copies it into ws current date
data then because we defined how the
fields of year
month and day line up within that data
name
layout we can just tell it to move the
year month
and day portions of that data into those
three variables
then in lines five and six we write out
our report header that's the financial
report four part
and the date info that follows it from
header two
we're writing those out to print rec and
we're writing them out there
from header one and header two
then we move spaces to print rec and
line seven
if we didn't do this we might leave
straight characters behind we want to
start out with the next series of moves
and writes assuming that we have a blank
record and then we write it out so if
you're following along at home which i
hope you are
we've got the financial report for then
the date
header and info then a blank space
because in line eight
we wrote out that line of spaces and put
it into the print rec
in line seven lines nine and ten
write out the column headers of account
last name
limit balance and those nifty dashes
that went under them
now all we have to do is print out the
data that goes underneath those headers
and
you know what that's where the lab comes
in that will show you how you can take
data from a file and use it to generate
a report with all the nice
formatting and spacing that makes it
nice and easy to read
after that why don't you report back
here for the next lesson
the path that a program takes is
sometimes referred to as its
logic does the user want to enter more
data if
yes then we'll jump to the part of our
code where we'll let them put in more
data
if they're done then we'll jump to the
part of our code where we're going to
process that data it's kind of like
hitting a fork in the road and we use
what we know
to inform that decision maybe you want
to look at a bunch of accounts and find
the ones that haven't been updated in
the last 60 days
in that case we're taking the difference
between the most recent update
and today's date and comparing that
difference to 60.
presumably if the difference is greater
than 60
then we're gonna do something special
with that account
that's all logic and unless we insert
our own logic
a program is going to run from the top
to the bottom until it's done
so we need to learn how to express what
we want to happen
in a program's logic three of the most
common types of cobol conditional
expressions are
general relation conditions class
conditions and sign conditions
and a lot of these are fairly simple
it's taking two operands comparing them
to one another and saying
is this greater than that or is this
equal to that or saying
is this numeric is this lowercase
sometimes because of the way our logic
is structured
we'll want to say is this not numeric
because maybe we asked the user for a
number
and we got that something like xx and we
need a way of saying
if this is not numeric go and prompt
that user again
and remind them we're looking for a
numeric answer
so whenever you're writing a conditional
expression they typically start out with
is and then there's a test or a
comparison afterwards and you can
between the test and the comparison
throw in a knot to flip that logic
around there's another important and
powerful tool you have in writing
program logic
known as conditional names these are
used primarily to say
the input we're taking needs to pass
this test
a conditional name is declared in the
working storage section
with an 88 level number in this case it
has to be an
88 level number we use a conditional
name to say the variable that i'm
under needs to match this and it can be
a literal
a series of literals or a pattern or
anything like that
and it's a good way of verifying user
input and again
it always has to be an 88 take a look at
this example
we move az into usa-state
then we enter this if statement if state
the only way this will pass as true is
if
state evaluates as true which in this
case will only pass if it's equal to tx
so we're going to say the state is not
texas
then here we're moving tx to usa-state
that will pass because it matches that
88 conditional statement it equals tx
why would we do something like this well
imagine instead of just putting in one
state we put in all
50. that makes sure somebody didn't put
in something like z
z or one two as their state or something
like that that didn't make any sense
so we can use conditional names as a way
of validating or limiting
data before we try and do something with
it there are other ways of implementing
this type of logic but being able
to have one place to define the scope of
the data
for a test is quite handy if we're
comparing values like
if this is greater than that we use
conditional
operators and those include is greater
than which can be written out as
is greater than sign remember those
alligator mounts
or is equal to which can be written out
with the equal sign
we can also say is greater than or equal
to with
is greater than equal to
we can take that concept and put it to
use in conditional expressions
that's where we put those if then else
statements to use
and you're probably already familiar
with those concepts either from another
programming language or just from
everyday talking logic if it's nice out
then i'm gonna go for a hike
else i'm just gonna stay inside and play
video games again we've defined
two possible outcomes and what will
inform that decision
the weather in code we might write
something like this
if facial expression is happy then say
hey i'm glad you're happy
otherwise say what can i do to make you
happy obviously we would want this
program to actually
do stuff if you're happy or not happy
maybe clap your hands
but this shows a basic if then else
statement we have another way of doing
this that's more useful if there's more
than two paths
and that's an evaluate statement we set
that up like this
first we evaluate facial expression when
it's happy we do this
when it's sad we do this when it's
perplexed we do this and we can keep on
going until we run out of possibilities
and then we hit the end where we just
say end evaluate
this comes in handy for menu type items
like press one to show account balance
press two to make withdrawal press three
to transfer money etc
each one of those could be a when in
this big evaluate statement
another thing that happens quite often
in programming is performing
some sort of function or set of steps
until something happens
maybe it's processing files until we've
reached the end or adding stops to this
truck driver's route until the truck is
full
if we're iterating over data
specifically tables
trying to find a specific entry we can
use search
statement that syntax looks like this
search the facial expression table until
you've found the index marked happy
then presumably we do something with
that record although in this example we
issue a stop
run so i guess they found happiness and
there's nothing left to do
let's get back to those conditions you
know we can say
if this number is equal to that number
that's a test of the relationship
between
two operands which can be numeric or
text
we can also use conditions to test the
content of a data item
like is numeric or is not alphabetic
lower or even
is kanji and for numbers we can say is
positive
is negative and is zero and just so you
know we're really only skimming the
surface here to read more about all
these conditions
visit the ibm knowledge center for
enterprise cobol
there's links for that in your material
we're coming up on that time
time to put what you've learned to use
in a lab and we're still working on
those reports
this time we're going to add in a
special case if we happen to be in the
state of virginia
which will result in a special entry in
the last line of your report
good luck and i'll see you back here
when you're done
cobalt is often used to process lots and
lots and lots and lots of data
and a lot of data is made up of lots and
lots and lots and lots of numbers
so in order to deal with all those
numbers we need to take a look at cobalt
arithmetic expressions that's
that's it that's that's the intro
nope more all right
let's put this graphics budget to use
it's math time
nice good job guys so
what is arithmetic expression well an
arithmetic expression can be built up
with numbers
variables that represent numbers the
figurative constant of
zero and any combination of those
enclosed within parentheses
including any combination of all that
that i just mentioned
having mathematical operations performed
on them
i think that about covers it for example
number of people minus number of staff
times three divided by eight
would be how many pizzas you need in
order to feed a
crowd of this many people assuming we're
not feeding the staff
each person will want three slices and
there are eight slices per pizza
that's a pretty good mix of variables
and literals and parentheses
and we can spell expressions out with
plus
minus times divided by and you can also
use two asterisks or
stars to show exponentiation so
2 star star 8 is 2 to the 8th
power meaning we keep doubling two eight
times that's
2 4 8 16 32 64 128 256
2 to the eighth equals 256. sometimes it
makes sense to spell out our arithmetic
expressions using the compute command
this can help make your code more
readable or just focus a series of
arithmetic operations in one place
so we can say compute z equals a
plus b divided by c exponent d
minus e we can also say compute x
y z equals all of that and it will
assign the answer of whatever that might
be
to all three variables x y and z
now you've probably heard of the order
of operations before and
if a part of your brain lit up that you
haven't heard from in a while
the word pemdas probably does the same
that is the order
in which we tackle an expression
starting with parentheses
then exponents multiplication division
addition and subtraction
pemdas by default cobalt will evaluate
expressions this way
if you want to either circumvent that
order or
you want to make it more clear for
yourself or others who are reading your
code you can also enclose
sections of your expressions in
parentheses cobalt will start with the
most
nested part of the expression the part
enclosed in the most parentheses
and then keep working its way out after
that it'll look at the unary operators
positive negative then exponents then
multiplication and division from left to
right
and then addition and subtraction from
left to right
that means that an arithmetic expression
must begin with either a
left parenthesis a unary operator or an
operand in the form of a literal number
or a variable representing a number
there are limitations to how far you can
push arithmetic expressions in cobol
the first is that exponents in fixed
point expressions cannot be more than
nine
digits if the compiler sees this it'll
truncate it and you will get a
diagnostic message
also while the data descriptions of
operands in expressions don't need to be
the same
meaning you can multiply a two-digit
number by a four-digit number
the maximum size of each operand is
either 18 or 19 decimal digits
depending on the compiler option used if
you're working with data that requires
either very big numbers or a
very high degree of precision make sure
you know if you're using compatibility
or
extended mode for arithmetic there are
also considerations to
consider when dealing with the rounding
of data
and there's more to get into that we
can't cover in its entirety here
but that's all spelled out in the
procedure division statements
cobalt language reference as you've
probably guessed we're going to get to
use some of these new skills in the
upcoming lab
check out this change to the working
storage section here
we've got t limit and t balance there's
some big numbers in there
and we'll learn more about data types in
the upcoming data type
section but i can tell you right now
those are big numbers or at least
able to represent big numbers they're a
comp three data type
and they start out with a value of zero
and look at this we've got what looks
like more header type content except
we're calling it trailer
and i'm not a betting man but i think
that's going to come at the
end it looks like it's showing us some
sort of totals so
that makes sense too and then in the
read next record paragraph we now have a
perform
limit balance total line which is
calling this
which is two compute statements which
look like they're keeping a running
total of the balance in total
from every line it's processing hmm
of course we're gonna write it out so
we've got this right
t limit t balance paragraph which moves
the running totals into the
dash o variable so that when we write
the trailer lines out the actual values
are gonna show up in there those are the
parts you'll need to finish this
sections lab and
by my calculations it's time to get to
[Music]
work
computers don't have fingers
i mean do they i mean i guess
no no they no they don't except what
about
no no no computers computers do not have
fingers let's let's just stick with that
so so when a computer is thinking of a
number like the number eight
it's not going like this it's lighting
up little bits of memory that
represent that number eight it's got its
own methods of taking numbers
letters and other concepts and
representing them electronically
one of the ways you can make sure your
programs are running as quickly and
efficiently as possible
is by choosing the best way for cobalt
to represent that data
in its memory let's start out with
numerical representation there are
five different computational value
representations
let's start with comp one comp 1 is also
known as a
single precision floating point number
representation
this is useful for numbers that are very
small and close to 0 or
very large up to 10 to the power of 38
however comp one has somewhat limited
precision
it only has about seven significant
decimal digits
anything beyond that gets rounded so a
value like
1 234 567.89
that rate there is nine digits and it's
going to get rounded which if you're
dealing with dollars and cents
you might not want to happen but for
simple numbers
a comp one might work then there's comp
2. this is a double precision floating
point numeric representation
and this can handle bigger numbers about
10 to the power of 307
it has more significant digits up to
about 15
so it goes further than comp 1 in all
regards but it is still
somewhat limited and then there's can
you guess
we did comp 1 comp 2 yes you in the back
no it's actually comp 3 comp 3
and this is where it gets interesting
this is what's known as a
bcd or binary coded decimal
this is by far the most utilized numeric
value representation in
cobol it is also somewhat unique and
native to the mainframe computer and z
architecture and with good reason it has
to do with
decimal fractions when you do lots and
lots of operations with decimal
fractions and the data is stored in
binary
that's when you start to get rounding
issues representing that data in binary
coded decimal
avoids these issues it exactly
represents values with decimal places
and can go up to 31 decimal digits
ask someone in a banking credit card or
payment processing industry why they
depend on cobalt
and they're probably going to mention
bcd binary code of decimal
and decimal fractions and then there's
comp 4. comp 4 is only capable of
representing integers
so if you're dealing with something like
a counter or you're only working in
integers
using comp 4 has you covered there and
then there's comp
5 which is the same as com4 but with it
you can specify
the position of a decimal point it's got
space efficiency of comp 4
with the exactness of com3 the drawback
there is that cannot exceed
18 decimal digits so there's your
numerical value representations
numbers are good but sometimes you want
to use letters
and you'll be happy to know that
cobalt's got you covered there as well
there's ebcdec which stands for extended
binary coded decimal interchange code
and ascii which stands for american
standard code for
information interchange and it's not
like one supports bigger words than the
other it really just comes down to how
the characters are represented in the
computer's memory
ebcdec has eight bits per character
ascii uses seven
and the characters are distributed
across the possible combinations of
those bits
differently today the only place you're
likely to see ebsydeck code is if you're
on an ibm mainframe
most everywhere else uses ascii or
unicode however
just keep this in mind if you're working
on programs written a long time ago
because
every once in a while you'll go to load
some data and it'll show up looking all
weird
your first instinct should be to say is
it possible that this data is
ebsedec and i'm trying to load it in
ascii or vice versa because
that happens quite often and now you'll
know and you'll be prepared
in this slab you'll deal with an issue
just like that where
spoiler alert there's a mismatch between
external data and the cobalt
representation of that data
there's a hint and an explanation in
there to help you along because
this is a tricky one
if you're like me one of the things you
like about cobalt is how straightforward
each line of code within a program is it
does what it says it's going to do
and there's really no mystery about what
do this
until this happens means however
sometimes you need to do something
beyond just add two numbers together or
print out a line of text
and it would be a shame if every time
you needed to for example
turn a string of characters from
lowercase to uppercase you had to go and
build that paragraph of logic
all by yourself first off you're just
repeating work and
more importantly that's important code
logic that needs to work right
every single time being added onto
whatever the primary role of the program
that you're writing
is there's got to be a better way
well fortunately cobalt has a number of
what are called
intrinsic functions built in that you
can use
and if you're working with business data
chances are there's something in there
for
you don't worry it's not like there's
500 new functions you have to keep track
of
the most recent release of enterprise
cobalt for z os
includes 70 intrinsic functions and they
fall into the categories of
math statistics date time
financial character handling and
general let's take a look at some of
those intrinsic functions they all
follow the format
of function then the name of the
function
and then any arguments passed to that
function in parentheses
for example look at this we've got two
variables
item one and item two item one has hello
world
in it with a capital h and a capital w
the rest lower case
and then there's item two which is empty
and we're going to display
item one which should look exactly like
it does up here with that capital h
and capital w then we're using the
uppercase and
lowercase intrinsic functions to show
item 1
in both uppercase and lowercase form
note that this is just being called
in the display function so it's not
altering the
stored data that's just how it's going
to show up when the display goes to show
it
then in this line we're moving the upper
cased version of item one
into item two and then displaying it so
in this last line if we display item two
it'll show
hello world in all caps that's going to
come in handy and making sure we don't
have any duplicate values otherwise
first street with lowercase st would be
a different entry than
first street with an uppercase st which
happens quite often
if we just uppercase everything we can
be sure that all the data coming in
is case insensitive there's also math
intrinsic functions
got a bunch of values that you want
summed up you could line them all up and
make an equation out of it
or you could say compute x equals
function sum a b
c divided by d that'll sign x the value
of a
plus b plus c divided by d and just like
before
anything within a pair of parentheses as
seen as one
operand and it needs to get figured out
before totaling the sum
but wait there's more what about dates
and times i mean come on man
cobalt's got you covered check out this
code we've got a variable called
yyyy mmdd length of eight gonna be
filled with numbers
and another one called integer form that
one's signed
with nine spaces we can use the function
of
current date with the argument of
one colon eight and move that into the
first variable
what's going on there well we're
specifying the output
in this case we want the output from
character one
that's the one through eight that's the
eight which just happens to be where the
year
month and day live within that output
then we want another function integer of
date
to turn that date into a number that
number is the number of days that have
passed
since january 1st 1601 so
it's going to be a big number but it's
also not likely you'll need to go back
much further than 1601
so pretty safe bet anyway what we have
now is essentially a
count of days with that we can add
90 to it and now we're talking about a
date that's 90 days from
now you see what we're doing now we're
going to use another function
to transform that integer form back into
year month and day form using the date
of integer function see what we're doing
there we flipped
it and now we wind up with what is a
nicely formatted date
in the form of year month day
and that's 90 days into the future
because we added 90 to it
and that takes into account going
through all the months of different
lengths
leap years and all that stuff intrinsic
functions and there's more lots more
like
60 something more keep that in mind as
you're writing code and you think to
yourself
gee i can't believe i have to write this
out by hand because there just might be
an intrinsic function
that you can use right there intrinsic
functions sound like something you might
want to try
oh well guess what act now and you can
do
just that with this intrinsic functions
lab
get yours today
[Music]
we are at the last section of this
cobalt series
first off i am extremely glad you made
it here and i hope you feel a lot more
confident
in your own abilities as a cobalt
programmer of course
the world goes on from here there are
lots more functions
methods and ways of dealing with files
and input to explore
but if you made it this far you can
tackle anything else you come across
you'll be able to understand the syntax
plug it into your code
make requested changes port a program
from one system to another
you've got all that just like with any
other programming language the internet
is full of code samples
mini exercises and forms with people
looking to help
go to the open mainframe project and go
into the cobol section on there
for a good head start on those resources
whether cobol is your first programming
language or your 15th or your 50th
i hope you've learned what this
specialized language is all about
and you'll see why it's used so widely
in highly transactional systems
all around the world from our team to
you
thank you for watching thank you for
participating and we wish you the best
in all that you do
stop run
you